- C'est le retour de la
roulotte, cette institution
- Des sourires,
des applaudissements
et des familles surprises
de retrouver des arts vivants,
bien en vie, au coeur de
leur parc de quartier.
- Elle regarde beaucoup la télé,
mais une pièce de théâtre,
c'est une autre expérience.
- C'est comme une petite
histoire avant de se coucher.
- Ah! Monsieur Paul!
- "Le rêve de M. Paul - L'autre
histoire de La Roulotte" est
un conte théâtral qui raconte
de manière fantaisiste la folle
aventure de cette vénérable
institution fondée en 1952.
- Ça fait 68 ans que ça existe,
La Roulotte. Ce projet-là,
c'est du génie là, dans le sens
que c'est tellement le fun que
ça existe, puis qu'on puisse
offrir ça à des jeunes
tous les étés. Puis que
ça se perpétue d'année en année
comme ça, c'est... ça veut dire
que l'idée même, à la base,
était brillante et importante.
- Si j'ai fait de la mise
en scène, c'est à cause de
La Roulette! La Roulette a été
mon école, a été l'école
à tout le monde!
- Paul Buissonneau, un immigrant
français, débarque au Québec
et fonde en 1952 avec Claude
Robillard, alors directeur
des parcs de Montréal,
La Roulotte, un véhicule
de diffusion culturelle dans
les parcs qui deviendra
une institution.
PHILIPPE ROBERT, auteur, metteur
en scène, "Le rêve de M. Paul"
- Claude Robillard a eu
cet idée. Il y avait ce vieux
véhicule en restauration
et il est allé voir Paul
Buissonneau. Le noyau de
ce qui fait La Roulotte
pour moi, c'est le véhicule
et tout ce qu'il évoque,
tout ce qu'il porte de magie,
d'histoires, vraies ou
inventées, et de contes, aussi.
- L'idée, un peu comme dans
les sports amateurs, c'est de
réunir des gens des quartiers
autour d'une ferveur commune,
mais cette fois, le théâtre.
BOZIDAR KRCEVINAC, comédien
- Moi, je pense fondamentalement
que c'est essentiel, que
c'est un droit d'avoir
accès au théâtre. Il y a
ces enfants-là que c'est leur
première pièce qu'ils vont voir.
- Une troupe qui, depuis 68 ans,
initie le public et forme
la relève. De Jean-Louis
Millette à Mathieu Ricard,
ce sont des générations
de comédiens qui on fait
leurs premières armes
avec La Roulotte.
Cette année, c'est au tour
des diplômés de 2020 et 2021
de l'École nationale de théâtre
et du conservatoire.
JEANE LANDRY-PROULX, comédienne
- Je me souviens, je suis
rentrée au conservatoire,
puis j'avais vu les années
précédentes de La Roulotte,
petite, on m'amenait voir
La Roulotte. Fait que c'était
déjà quelque chose qui
se dessinait dans ma tête
de me dire : wow! J'aimerais ça
en faire partie.
- Peu de gens le savent...
- Pour éviter de créer
des attroupements, les dates
et lieux des représentations ne
sont pas annoncés à l'avance.
Il faut donc ouvrir l'oeil
ou encore l'oreille parce que
la troupe a également créé
un balado des contes avec
la participation de Marcel
Sabourin, pour poursuivre
cette belle tradition d'aller
à la rencontre du public
où qu'il soit et peu importe
les circonstances.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M